praise soul after almost a year and a
half raised by wolves season 2 is back
with all the lactating mystery we've
come to know and love you know that's
breast milk
if you need a refresher on what happened
at the end of season one definitely
check out my video on that which i'll
leave a link to in the description below
and for those of you who are new here
these videos are deep dives into the
show's biggest mysteries keep in mind i
will be referencing elements from the
trailers to help uncover what the hell
is actually going on here on kepler 22b
and you'll want to stick around to the
very end as i'll be going over how this
android skeleton here becomes this and
may hold the key to one of the show's
biggest mysteries so without further ado
make sure to like and subscribe we have
two episodes to cover in this video
let's get into it a static pov of
mothers funny considering how mother
lost her eye that gave her the ability
to transform into a deadly necromancer
not very realistic is it an eye which
was last seen rammed down the throat of
marcus at the end of season 1 episode 9.
mother and father survive their journey
through the center of the earth to the
tropical zone and are rescued by a group
of atheists known as the collective up
until now it was believed only the
god-fearing mathrack possessed the ships
able to make the journey to kepler-22b
but as we learn from new character
decima the atheists managed to hijack a
methraic ship and make it on their own
we're not exactly sure how much time has
passed here only that it's been a while
since when mother is reunited with
campion she remarks how his voice has
lowered an octave the collective has
imprisoned the remaining myth rick and
subjected them to manual labor including
the dawning of bomb vests that are
triggered to go off should they venture
too far among the captured lucius and
justina from season one a particular
note are newcomers decima and an android
imprinted with the memory of her dead
daughter vril in roman mythology decimal
was one of the three fates and in charge
of birth ironic since decima lost a
daughter but the name itself is also a
reference to the religious act of
tithing decem comes from the latin word
for ten and the idea that everyone
should give one tenth of their earnings
to god considering how decima will later
team up with the religious zealot marcus
and how it's implied the two will become
romantic and perhaps even have a child
decima is a fantastic name for her as
mother and father are delivered to the
collective's commune we get a better
look at life in the tropical zone which
includes these giant whirlpools i wonder
if they're the result of those huge pits
created by those giant snake-like
creatures we saw the bones of in season
one after all we do find out the snake
mother gave birth to is impervious to
the acid water the collective is led by
an ai known as trust an ai which
coincidentally was created by the same
person who made mother and father that's
why when mother is first introduced to
it he greets her with the phrase
it's funny that the atheists don't
believe in a god but end up putting
their trust in a god-like supercomputer
called trust who dictates everything
they do for atheists like tamerlane this
constitutes an attack on his freedom and
ability to choose it's an interesting
role reversal as the atheists now seem
to be the ones against freedom and the
mithraic led by marcus open to it now i
did find that the trust computer did
look oddly like one of the data cards
mother found in season one although that
may be a coincidence speaking of those
cards marcus finds one containing a tree
with five branches representing the tree
of knowledge from the pentagonal
prophecy remember that this prophecy
foretells of an orphan boy in an empty
land wielding a sword forged in seoul's
light that will lead people to the tree
of knowledge in the trailer we see such
a five branch tree just like the data
card marcus believes he's this prophet
remember he was orphaned and grew up a
child soldier but there's evidence to
suggest paul or even the snake itself
could be this prophet after all both
paul and the snake were orphaned marcus
finds a symbol of saul in a cave a sign
that he's on the right path and must
recruit more followers this also hints
at beings that lived on the planet years
ago we've seen neanderthal skulls
devolved human-like entities and in the
trailer we'll even get this thing which
kinda looks like this character from the
k paintings in season one marcus will
end up saving decima and vreel
recruiting them as his first followers
meanwhile sue and mother talk about the
signal or voice the one that turned
marcus mad and tried to manipulate
mother against her own family it seems
this signal can't penetrate the strong
electromagnetic field found in the
tropical zone but if they can find out
where it's coming from they may be able
to get some answers while foraging
father and tally discover a cave with
weird claw-like markings there they
uncover the bones of an android millions
of years old this android has the same
honeycomb skeletal frame like mother as
well as the being in mother's vision
from episode 10. we'll see that father
has taken it upon himself to reconstruct
this android over the course of the
season perhaps it will have some answers
but back to the honeycomb symbols you
might have noticed they can be found all
over the planet like these much larger
ones on the beach father will later find
out that when exposed to light the
honeycomb frame provides a suitable
environment for life is it possible then
that the entire planet of kepler is
itself some sort of similar entity
capable of growing its own plants and
even ecosystems campion and pollen cover
two interesting objects while out
forging an old dodecahedron like the one
found in mother's vision as well as a
snake egg can i offer you a nice egg in
this trying time yeah he's got an egg
paul and champion aren't sure what's
inside this object they think it could
perhaps be a map or seeds but if it's to
be open they'll need a laser the egg on
the other hand belongs to the snake when
champion goes to return it he has this
weird connection with it later telling
paul that he sensed the snake would
never hurt him and was just trying to
communicate perhaps because they're
technically siblings they both came from
the same mother that's why when mother
comes to campion stage she lactates her
body senses the child she gave birth to
the snake is near her in episode 2
mother is on the hunt to take down the
snake but something tells me she won't
go through with it it's her child after
all and why would they have this scene
where a young boy tells her that even
those things you think are scary can be
beautiful unless it served some other
purpose mother is tasked with a new job
punishing tamerlane for burning a symbol
of saul in front of their home something
that's considered a hate crime this is
the last straw which will see tamerlane
defect to marcus marcus shows decima his
damaged cards suggesting that they may
contain data as to the whereabouts of
the tree of knowledge but they need to
get their hands on undamaged ones which
may be hard to do since paul burned them
at the end of season 1. regardless the
pentagonal prophecy states that in order
to find the tree you'll need to wield a
sword forged in seoul's light marcus
believes this sword could be mother
scalpel he took from her in season 1.
we've seen mother use this in episode 4
when she removed the tracking devices
from the children's bodies in the
trailer we see it welled by this unknown
person attacking decima could it be real
sue let me know what you think in the
comments below and what is arguably my
favorite part of the two episodes a
group of people from the collective lock
themselves in this building so father
and the children will be eaten by the
snake but they end up getting themselves
sent into the acid ocean chef's kiss
with nine dead the collective is
instructed by trust to hunt down the
serpent father's job is that of a
shepherd hurting a group of methacric
prisoners to act as bait only to be
eaten and then the bombs on their chest
detonated in the teaser however we see
the prisoners with the bombs safely
removed you may have also noticed
father's weapon this sort of shock staff
will later see this used on marcus who
seems impervious to its power paul
however has different plans he recalls
the story of saul and the serpent and
believes the serpent may help him get
his dodecahedron back mother also gets
her nipple seal it's kind of interesting
since her whole reason for being is that
of a mother she's now turning her back
on that after commandeering a collective
tank marcus and decimate learn of the
snake believing it to be the sort of
soul that the prophet must master in
order to lead them to the tree of
knowledge they find out that it's not
entirely organic so it seems as though
it has taken on both organic and
inorganic traits of its mother and
whoever the father is all we know is
that when mother came out of that weird
cyber sex session in season one she was
magically pregnant at the same time real
has been instructed to venture back to
the caves but runs into paul and campion
she says she can lead them to the snake
since she's been programmed with a
tracking software this leads us with
several factions all converging on the
snake for various reasons we have mother
going to kill it father and the
prisoners champion paul and vreel as
well as marcus and the mithraic but the
episode ends with mother using her flame
breath to set fire to the snake's dead
skin saying that it deserves only death
for being the killer of children notice
the giant weapon she carries the same as
this one from the trailer where she is
in her flying pose but she needs that
eye if she's gonna fly now there is one
thing i need to talk about it's this
person these two images look like they
could be father's workshop the place
where he's rebuilding that android let
me know what you think on the left you
can see he's made more progress with the
right being the finished product we also
see this entity in this futuristic
setting attached to all these wires in
the official trailer we'll see her walk
in this room with these pods and i'm
wondering if these pods are similar to
the cryopods used on the arcs we also
see her muffling mother either to keep
her quiet or to kill her i did some
sleuthing and it seems as though imdb
leaked the name of a character named
grandmother if this is the ancient
android it's totally possible this is
some previous version of mother hence
her name grandmother and this android
would have information from millions of
years ago again this is all for fun and
i want to hear your thoughts and
comments of the first two episodes below
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like and subscribe i'll be covering
every episode this season so you'll want
to stick around for that you can also
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
[Music]